GOVERNMENT THEY WANT AND YOU
SHOULD NOT FORGET THAT.
NOW THAT WE KNOW ALL THIS, WHAT
HAPPENS NEXT?
IN SOME WAYS HE IS THE CENTER OF
THE STORY.
A RETIRED ARMY COLONEL WHO LAST
YEAR ADVISED THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ON FOREIGN
POLICY.
HE COAUTHORED A MEMO ASKING U.S.
TROOPS TO LEAVE AFGHANISTAN
FINALLY AFTER 20 YEARS.
THAT MEMO IS ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT MARK MILLIE DECIDED TO
ORGANIZE A COUP.
HE JOINS US IN STUDIOS TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
WE WERE TALKING BEFORE AIR AND
YOU COME UP SUDDENLY, DID NOT
SEEM SHOCKED BY THIS.
IT DOES SEEM THAT PEOPLE WHO
DON'T KNOW THE SYSTEM AS WELL AS
YOU DO STUNNING THAT THE STAFF
WOULD BE SECRETLY CALLING A
CHINESE GENERAL IN SAYING WE
WILL WARN YOU IF WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE AGAINST YOU.
BUT THIS DOES NOT SHOCK YOU.
>> I'M NOT SHOCKED.
KEEP IN MIND WE HAVE YET TO HEAR
FROM GENERAL MILLIE.
WE ARE ACCEPTING WHAT BOB
WOODWARD WROTE IN THE BOOK IS
ESSENTIALLY GOSPEL TRUTH AND I'M
NOT DOUBTING WOODWARD'S
INTEGRITY BUT WE KNOW FROM
EXPERIENCE OF THAT FROM TIME TO
TIME, HE IS SOMEWHAT FLEXIBLE IN
THE INTERPRETATION MADE, PUT A
SPIN ON IT THAT MAY OR MAY NOT
BE ACCURATE.
>> Tucker: I HOPE THIS IS ONE
OF THESE CASES BUT MILLIE HAS
NOT RESPONDED AS OF 8:07
EASTERN.
THE CLAIM IS THAT HE MADE A
PHONE CALL TO HIS COUNTERPART IN
THE CHINESE MILITARY AND THE
FORMER PRESIDENT HAS ISSUED
STATEMENT SUGGESTING THAT HE DID
NOT KNOW.
SO THAT ALONE, IS THIS WITHIN
BOUNDS OR IS THIS IS FAR
OUT-OF-BOUNDS AS IT SEEMS?
>> NO, THERE'S SOME THINGS WE
KNOW, FIRST OF ALL THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE JOINT CHIEFS HAS NO
STATUTORY AUTHORITY OVER
OPERATIONAL FORCES OF ANY TIME.
THAT MEANS HE'S NOT IN POSITION
TO ORDER ANYONE IN THE
ARMED FORCES TO SAY OR DO
ANYTHING.
HE CAN'T DO IT.
HE IS PREEMINENTLY THE SENIOR
MILITARY ADVISOR TO THE
PRESIDENT.
THAT'S WHAT HE IS, SO IN THEORY
BEFORE HE WOULD MAKE SUCH A
PHONE CALL HE WOULD DISCUSS THE
SUBJECT OF THE PHONE CALL WITH
THE PRESIDENT, THE COMMANDER IN
CHIEF.
HE CERTAINLY WOULD NOT DO
SOMETHING WITHOUT COORDINATING
WITH THE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR AND THE SECRETARY OF
STATE, BECAUSE THIS IS BEYOND
DEFENSE.
THIS IS A FOREIGN POLICY
STATEMENT THAT HE IS MAKING.
THESE ARE IMPORTANT THINGS TO
UNDERSTAND.
THE THIRD THING --
>> Tucker: SO IF THAT IS TRUE,
IF THIS ACCOUNT IS CORRECT, FROM
LAYMAN'S PERSPECTIVE, IT SOUNDS
LIKE A GRAVE OFFENSE.
>> HE'S VIOLATED THE LAW, IF
THIS TURNS OUT TO BE TRUE.
WE REALLY NEED TO HEAR FROM HIM,
CONGRESS NEEDS TO BRING HIM
OVER, HE NEEDS TO BE PLACED
UNDER OATH AND ANSWER QUESTIONS
IN FRONT OF THE SENATE ABOUT
THIS ENTIRE AFFAIR.
HE'S BEEN VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD.
THEY THEN WILL HAVE TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THE LAW HAS BEEN
BROKEN BUT FROM OUR STANDPOINT
KNOWING WHAT WE DO ABOUT WHO HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO DO WHAT AND HOW
HE FITS IN WITHIN THE BROAD
SCHEME OF THINGS, THIS IS WRONG.
REMEMBER, THE PRESIDENT IS NOT
ABLE TO ACT INDEPENDENTLY AND
LAUNCH A NUCLEAR WEAPON.
HE HAS A CONSULTATIVE PROCESS.
PEOPLE WHO ARE MEMBERS OF THE
STANDING COMMITTEE WITH WHOM
THIS IS DISCUSSED, THIS CHAIN OF
COMMAND THAT RUNS THROUGH THE
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE, THE
STRATEGIC OFFENSE HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH GENERAL MILLIE PEER
GENERAL MILLIE AS AN ADVISOR CAN
SPEAK UP AND SUGGEST WHAT THEY
SHOULD OR SHOULDN'T DO BUT I
THINK THERE IS SOMETHING ELSE
THAT PEOPLE NEED TO UNDERSTAND.
IF GENERAL MILLIE FEELS AS
STRONGLY AS HE APPARENTLY DOES
ACCORDING TO THIS DESCRIPTION,
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE HAS AT
ANY TIME THE RIGHT TO SAY I
CANNOT BE PART OF THIS WITHOUT
PREJUDICE.
THAT DOES NOT MEAN HE HAS TO
LEAVE THE ARMED FORCES, IT MEANS
HE LEADS HIS POSITION AND
SOMEONE ELSE CAN BE BROUGHT IN.
THAT IS WHAT YOU DO IF YOU FEEL
STRONGLY THAT YOU ARE DEALING
WITH SOMEONE YOU CANNOT SUPPORT.
>> Tucker: I WILL JUST MAKE
THIS CALL BECAUSE IT IS VERY
OBVIOUS, MILLIE IS A
DISHONORABLE MAN.
WE KNOW THIS BECAUSE OF HIS
TESTIMONY BEFORE CONGRESS.
I THINK IT IS VERY CLEAR.
ON THE OTHER HAND, WE KNOW FOR A
FACT THAT HE WAS SPEAKING IN A
CAPACITY, I GUESS, AS A
POLITICAL PARTISAN TO THE
LEADERS OF THE OTHER PARTY.
>> YES, THAT IS TRUE.
>> COLLUDING AGAINST TRUMP ON A
POLITICAL AND PARTISAN LEVEL.
>> HE MADE IT CLEAR ON NUMEROUS
OCCASIONS THAT HE WAS TALKING
DIRECTLY TO THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE NANCY PELOSI AND
SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER,
REASSURING THEM THAT HE WAS IN
CONTROL OF THINGS AT THE
PENTAGON.
PLENTY OF PEOPLE WHO SAW THAT
INCLUDING THE ACTING SECRETARY
OF DEFENSE.
THAT IS UNFORTUNATE.
>> Tucker: THAT SEEM SO
CORRUPT.
>> IT IS SO CORRUPT IT IS
SUGGESTS TO ME THAT THIS IS A
ONE TO SAUL, HE THE WIND.
THAT MUCH I CAN ACCEPT WITHOUT
HESITATION.
IT'S JUST THE ENTIRE NARRATIVE I
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THAT EXAMINED
AND EXPLORED UNDER OATH IN THE
RIGHT SETTING.
>> Tucker: I'VE GOT TO SAY
MAYBE THE MOST PROFOUND CASUALTY
HERE IS THE FAITH THAT PEOPLE
HAVE THAT OUR SYSTEM WORKS AND
THAT THEIR VIEWS ARE REPRESENTED
IN THE WAY THE COUNTRY IS RUN,
THAT IS THE MOST BASIC PROMISE
OF DEMOCRACY AND IT SEEMS TIME
AND TIME AGAIN AS WE LEARN THESE
DETAILS THAT THE OPINIONS OF THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE HERE AND PAY FOR
AT ALL HAVE NO BEARING ON
ANYTHING.
>> I THINK IT IS VERY CLEAR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE NOT
REPRESENTED BY WASHINGTON, D.C.
IT IS OCCUPIED TERRITORY.
RALPH NADER USED TO CALL
WASHINGTON OCCUPIED TERRITORY.
IT WAS OCCUPIED BY CORPORATIONS,
OCCUPIED AND CONTROLLED BY
DONORS, SO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AREN'T ASKED TO BEAR MUCH OF
ANYTHING ABOUT ANYTHING WHETHER
IT IS IMMIGRATION, GOING TO WAR
COME INTERVENING SOMEWHERE
MILITARILY, NONE OF THOSE THINGS
ARE DONE SO WE KNOW THAT IS
ALREADY A HUGE PROBLEM.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE ONE POINT
VERY CLEAR, THOUGH.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOT SOMEONE
WHO IS PREPARED TO LAUNCH A
NUCLEAR STRIKE OUT AGAINST
ANYONE.
THAT IS ABSURD NONSENSE ABSURD
NONSENSE.
>> Tucker: THE WHOLE THING IS
B.S.
TRUMP IS THE FIRST PRESIDENT
SINCE JIMMY CARTER WHO DIDN'T
LAUNCH A WAR.
RIGHT, YEAH, THE WHOLE THING IS
A LIE